[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actu l'assemblée au
sénat et avec moi pour présenter cette
émission brigitte boucher bonjour
brigitte bonjour dame et pour parcourir
cette semaine encore largement consacrée
aux retraites mais aussi marqué par
l'épidémie de coronavirus notre invité
est aujourd'hui marie le bec
bonjour bonjour et c'est brigitte qui
fait votre portrait bonjour harelbeke
vous êtes né à vernon dans l'eure en
1990 vous êtes donc une toute jeune
député élu à seulement 27 ans dans les
yvelines un département que vous
connaissez bien pour y avoir fait vos
études louveciennes saint germain en
laye chatou vous êtes également
vice-présidente du groupe la république
en marche à l'assemblée dont vous portez
souvent la parole dans les médias
n'hésitant pas à entrer dans la mêlée ou
a botté en touche vous la fan de rugby
engagé en politique sous nicolas sarkozy
vous avez été encarté 9 ans à l'ump vous
savez aussi été attaché parlementaire du
député socialiste christian franqueville
mais seulement pendant 18 mois
pur produit du et en même temps vous
vous tourner vers emmanuel macron mais
pouvez-vous nier que ce et en même temps
penche un peu à droite
non c'est enfin je crois que
fondamentalement on a un programme qui
était assez clair qui était portée par
le président de la république qui visait
surtout engagé un certain nombre de
grandes transformations dans notre
système que ce soit des transformations
économiques où toutes les questions
autour de l'assignation à domicile la
question aussi des retraites puisque on
va en parler après qui est quand même un
projet très ambitieux et je crois qu'au
fond le sujet c'est pas de savoir si on
est plutôt un peu à droite ou plutôt un
peu à gauche ça dépend de l'actualité ça
dépend du texte qui est débattu ça
dépend de la politique est portée mais
surtout que ce soit clair où est ce
qu'on va
moi je trouve que malgré mes dix ans de
militantisme au sein des républicains on
a un peu on avait un peu perdu cette
capacité en france à projeter le pays
dans l'avenir alors vous restez avec
nous voici les titres de cette émission
le projet de loi retraites a pris la
direction du sénat il a été adopté cette
semaine à l'assemblée sans vote
après l'utilisation du 49 3 et le rejet
de deux motions de censure
droite et gauche ont dénoncé un passage
en force l'assemblée est touchée à son
tour par le coronavirus un député
fonctionnaires du palais bourbon sont
infectés le sénat débattu cette semaine
des mesures de santé publique prise par
l'exécutif pour faire face à l'épidémie
les sénateurs adoptent à l'unanimité un
congé de 15 jours en cas de deuil d'un
enfant ainsi qu'un accompagnement
psychologique à l'assemblée le refus
d'augmenter ce congé par les députés
marcheurs avaient suscité l'indignation
et on commence par le sujet
parlementaire phares les retraites
[Musique]
cette semaine le gouvernement a dû
affronter deux motions de censure contre
son projet de loi sur les retraites sans
surprise elles ont été rejetées mais
gauche et droite ont critiqué vertement
l'absence de vote sur ce texte le recid
hélène bonduelle une sur sa gauche une
sur sa droite
ce mardi soir dans l'hémicycle le
premier ministre est pris en tenaille
entre deux motions de censure
c'est peu dire que larmes du 49-3 sur
les retraites dégainer en plein week-end
est en pleine crise du coronavirus a
ulcéré l'opposition pour la motion de
gauche emmenée par les socialistes les
insoumis et les communistes
cette femme participe l'amateurisme du
gouvernement
il vous est en fait insupportable que
nous fassions respirait la démocratie
oui chers collègues tout depuis le début
de l'examen de ce texte prouve que vous
n'avez jamais voulu débattre et que vous
souhaitiez imposer coûte que coûte votre
réforme les républicains dénoncent un
fiasco parlementaire le devoir de la
droite c'est de censurer un gouvernement
faussement réformateurs qui est en train
de se fracasser sur la réalité d'une
réforme ratée ce 49 3 monsieur le
premier ministre il aura un coût
politique
je n'ai pas de doute sur l'issue de la
motion mais ce 49,3 vous sera très
certainement perdre dans un avenir
proche
votre majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale ce sera votre waterloo
politique
quatre heures de séance agitée et sans
surprise
faute de majorité les deux motions de
censure sont rejetés 148 voix pour
celles des républicains 91 pour la
motion de gauche
conséquence est considéré comme adopté
le projet de loi instituant un système
universel de retraite
le projet de réforme des retraites est
adoptée en première lecture et le
gouvernement assumera le texte sur
lequel j'engage la responsabilité du
gouvernement en application des
dispositions de l'article 49 alinéa 3
est un texte de compromis un texte qui a
évolué de l'assument
il a été enrichi prochaine étape le
sénat avant un retour à l'assemblée
nationale pour une adoption définitive
prévue avant l'été
marie lebey qu'est-ce que damien abad a
tort quand il dit que ce 49 3 va avoir
un coût politique pour vous celui de
vous faire perdre votre majorité ici à
l'assemblée
non je crois pas que ce soit une
histoire de 49,3 puisque ce qu'on voit
bien c'est que les députés ont été les
députés de la majorité extrêmement unie
soudée
même dans ce qu'on appelle généralement
la majorité élargie composée du modem de
d'agir pour justement le organiser le
quand-même défection cette semaine en
début de semaine le week-end dernier au
sénat mais celle là mais elle est juste
après le 49-3 on peut pas dire que
certains députés n ai pas fait un autre
choix mais ce sont des députés peut-être
qu'ils n'estiment et plus avoir leur
place au sein du groupe et
l'appartenance au sein d'un groupe vous
savez elle est très libre dans un
collectif à 300 vous avez jamais 100 %
des personnes qui sont satisfaites
moi je crois que sur la réforme des
retraites le consensus au delà du
véhicule législatif c'est de dire on a
besoin de réformer ce système il faut
qu'on mette tout en oeuvre pour qu'il
soit réformé et ça quand bien même il ya
des députés qui ont quitté la majorité
et on le regrette
il ya un accord craignant une sécession
de l'ale gauche au sein de votre groupe
on en parle de plus en plus on parle
même de l'émergence d'un nouveau groupe
parlementaire 9
on verra s'il ya un neuvième groupe qui
ce qui se crée je crois que de toute
façon ce serait un groupe qui serait
composé certainement aussi
deux non inscrits peut-être d'autres
d'autres personnalités venant d'autres
groupes
moi je m'inquiète pas ça le débat
parlementaire il peut vivre
il peut vivre dans une majorité qui est
plus restreinte en s'appuyant sur aussi
d'autres tendances d'autres courants
c'est aussi le principe de la vie
démocratique c'est aussi considéré que
effectivement ya jamais eu autant de
groupe à l'assemblée nationale que
toutes les tendances peuvent être
représentés et que ça nous oblige un
petit peu à rebâtir la façon dont on
travaille entre groupes parlementaires
est votre réaction au fait que tout de
même le 49-3 ça choque aussi les
français il ya un sondage qui a montré
que 70 % des français gardent
désapprouve le recours en 49 3 mais
parce que on estime souvent que le 49-3
c'est un passage en force pour un
exécutif qui n'a pas le soutien de sa
majorité
ce que je peux vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est que pour avoir fait un certain
nombre de réunions périodiques force
non c'est pas un passage en force parce
que l'exécutif et la majorité sont
d'accord on passe ce texte par le biais
du 49-3 parce qu'on n'a pas
d'alternative possible sauf que vous
aviez l'opinion avec vous avant la
réforme et vous l'avez contre vous après
cette réforme mais je crois pas qu'elle
soit contre nous honnêtement je sais que
vous allez me donner les chiffres des
sondages et en même temps est ce que je
vous dis c'est que on a fait vraiment
énormément de réunion publique sur ce
sujet il ya un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes qui sont légitimes mais il
ya un consensus déjà autour de ce
qu'elle est cette ambition garder la
répartition met en place un système
universel corriger un certain nombre
d'inégalités créer de nouveaux droits il
ya un conseiller vous ne craignez pas un
vote sanction aux élections municipales
mais je crois que ces décors et les
envoie il ya toujours bien sûr ceux où
enfin dans le milieu médiatique et
politique on analysera toujours le
résultat du scrutin au regard de la
politique qui est menée au niveau
national
dans ma circonscription des communes
entre 35000 et 5000 habitants donc quand
même de taille importante
la plupart des candidats ne veulent pas
avoir d'étiquette parce qu'il ne
souhaite pas politiser le débat donc
certainement on analysera le scrutin
sous cet angle là mais ce que je crois
c'est que aujourd'hui si la réforme des
retraites
elle suscite des inquiétudes des
interrogations peut-être même des
oppositions si vous voulez c'est parce
que les français ne savent pas le
système dans lequel ils sont aujourd'hui
et c'est difficile même pour moi je veux
dire qui est beaucoup trop vite afin de
se projeter sur qu'est-ce qu'on aura à
la fin alors ce jeudi le deuxième volet
de la réforme des retraites le projet de
loi organique qui portent notamment sur
la gouvernance financière a été adoptée
à l'assemblée en l'absence d'amendements
motivée par la rap
or le débat entretenu par les insoumis a
tourné court face à cette absence de
dialogue
l'opposition de gauche a quitté
l'hémicycle écouter la députée france
insoumise clémentine autain à quoi
servent nos travaux mes chers collègues
après 1 49 3 sur l'essentiel la loi
ordinaire et alors que vous ne répondez
pas sur les question que nous vous
posons et les arguments on était là pour
amender on était là pour argumenter on
était là et prêt pour une confrontation
sur le fond c'est une mascarade
mes chers collègues c'est une mascarade
et maintenant je crois que pour les
oppositions à la gauche de cet hémicycle
il est temps de tirer le rideau ça
suffit et pour reprendre les termes de
l'écrivaine virginie despentes
nous aussi on se lève et on se marre et
l'opposition de droite a aussi quitté
l'hémicycle avant le vote de la loi
le résultat c'est que finalement vous
avez voté seul ce texte
est-ce que c'est pas le symbole de votre
incapacité à dialoguer non mais pour
reprendre les mots de clémentine autain
ce qui est une mascarade c'est
l'attitude des oppositions on voit bien
la france insoumise beaucoup de réponses
avaient été apportée en commission à
l'occasion des débats
vous savez les débats ils n'ont pas
démarré jeudi à 12h30 quand ils ont
décidé de partir des musiques celle des
mariannes mercredi la veille avait
beaucoup bu beaucoup de réponses déjà
apporté sur ce sujet on sait bien qu'il
ne voulait pas de ce texte
on sait bien qu'ils voulaient faire de
l'obstruction pour autant chacun d'avoir
des impératifs de campagne donc ça ne
doit pas leur déplaire de pouvoir aussi
terminé le tag haut qu'avant le avant le
week-end et c'est pareil les
républicains jeudi de clore les
républicains ont quitté l'hémicycle
parce qu'il voulait un vote solennel
pour l'heure refusé sur un texte aussi
important parce que ça c'est pas qu'on
leur refus c'est qu'ils ne l'ont pas
demandé à l'occasion de la conférence
des présidents qui s'est tenue un peu
plus tôt dans la dans la semaine si je
ne me trompe pas le mardi il avait
l'occasion de faire cette demande ils ne
l'ont pas fait on va pas convoqué pour
le bon plaisir de républicains une
conférence des présidents de manière
tout à fait exceptionnelle pour encore
une fois retardé les débats je crois que
c'est quand même ça le message fort
c'est de dire ne soyons pas naïfs c'est
la volonté de retarder les débats bien
en tout cas après l'adoption de la
réforme à l'assemblée la balle est
désormais dans le camp de la chambre
haute la commission des affaires
sociales a débuté ses travaux en
auditionnant trois économistes mercredi
trois experts très critique au drive
états pour entamer leurs travaux les
sénateurs ont demandé les
clay rage des économistes sur trois
thèmes bien différent les effets de la
réforme pour l'état et la fonction
publique
ensuite ce qui fonctionne ou pas chez
nos voisins à l'étranger ceux qui ont
déjà mis en place le système à points
est enfin question plus précise antoine
bozio l'inspirateur de la réforme
ils lui ont demandé quels étaient les
décalages avec ses préconisations des
questions bien différentes mais des
réponses qui convergent les économistes
et met d'abord des réserves sur le
système à points et sur son indexation
aujourd'hui c'est un objet statistiques
non identifiés sur lequel on peut faire
de très nombreux scénarios différents
j'étais critiques pendant une quinzaine
d'années des systèmes à point critique
de la façon dont à l'agirc-arrco des
règles discrétionnaire mal maîtrisée
pouvait avoir des conséquences critique
du fait qu'un système en points
il faut avoir confiance dans la valeur
du point dans leur ligne de mire aussi
les concessions du gouvernement en
décembre sous la pression sociale
notamment l'application de la réforme
aux générations 1975 au lieu de 1963 ce
qui la retarde ce qui pose problème car
les complexités qui est liée à la
multiplication des règles vont continuer
à exister même si leur poids certes va
décroître
petit à petit ils pointent enfin des
études d'impact flou qui renforce le
sentiment de méfiance des français pour
un système qui devait être plus juste
sur le papier je pense que c'est
dommageable pour en réalité la bonne
conception d'une réforme qui j'en reste
persuadé aurait pu faire l'objet d'un
beaucoup plus large consensus
le manque d'études d'impact sur les
finances publiques c'est bien ce qui
pose problème aussi à la commission les
sénateurs se sont émus de devoir voter
une réforme sans aucune visibilité
marie lebey qu'on a entendu un notamment
via l'un des inspirateurs de la rai
femme antoine bozio il dit bien cette
réforme
elle aurait pu faire l'objet d'un
beaucoup plus large consensus
est ce que ça vous étonne cet avis
unanimement critiques de tous ces
économistes en moins quand j'entends
antoine bozio je trouve qu'on se paye un
peu de mots parce que henry
et c'est effectivement c'est une réforme
en profondeur donc c'est une informe qui
est ambitieuse donc forcément elle
soulève un certain nombre de questions
elle soulève un certain nombre de
challenge aussi pu y avait des des
sujets qui semblait pas spécialement
être corrélée aux retraites la question
du divorce la question des pacs les
évolutions de la société qui sont
rentrés dans le débat et qu'il faut
qu'il faut intégrer et qu'il faut
considérer et tout ça ça donne
effectivement une réforme qui est très
dense qui est parfois apparaît comme
comme très complexe mais ce que je
comprends pas c'est que aujourd'hui et
c'est peut-être un décalage
générationnel vous me direz on puisse
accepter de regarder un système un
système qui est bien qui permet à chaque
français d'avoir une retraite le
regarder mourir en considérant que c'est
juste soit comme les républicains un
petit peu de paramètres et un peu de
financiers à résoudre soit qu' on peut
avoir une réforme qui repose sur un beau
coup dire qu'on a le meilleur système de
retraite au monde aussi bien que aimé la
société notre système est très bien la
répartition ça fonctionne très bien
ce qui est important c'est que cette
elle s'adapte mieux à nos carrières
aujourd'hui on n'a plus dé carrière qui
sont linéaires où on rentre dans une
entreprise ont fait 25 ans ou 35 ans
dans la même entreprise
et puis on arrive à se projeter beaucoup
plus rares on a aussi des jeunes qu'il
ya quand même la fois sur le financement
qui a pas été levés on a vu que cette
semaine encore l'institut montaigne
disait que c'était pas 12 milliards
qu'il fallait trouver d'ici 2030 mais 20
milliards on ne sait plus qui faut-il
croire finalement ses économistes le
gouvernement l'institut montaigne mais
il ya la question du financement vous
savez le corps avec 10 entre 7 et 17
milliards moi j'étais pas surpris par le
chiffre de l'institut montaigne suis pas
non plus surpris critique notre réforme
puisque le figaro quand même eu
l'amabilité de rappeler que c'est un
think tank assez libéral et qu'il ne se
positionne plutôt sur la ligne défendue
par les républicains moi je comprends
mais c'est vrai que c'est une réforme
qui est ambitieuse mais c'est pour ça
aussi qu'on se donne le temps de la
mettre en place
on a le débat parlementaire certains
disent ils est très resserré en réalité
en haletant mais surtout c'est la
transition la transition est très longue
juste est-ce qu'il faut laisser quinze
jours de plus au sénat pour vous pour
attendre les conclusions de la
conférence de financement n'est pas à 15
jours près je crois que c'est ce que le
premier ministre a demandé et depuis le
début on a toujours dit on veut
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
ce sera des acteurs importants dans le
futur système et donc si ça nous permet
d'adopter malgré tout le texte avant
l'été
moi je suis pas avec un jour près on
passe à présent à l'autre actualité
marquante de la semaine c'est l'épidémie
de coronavirus
[Musique]
un sujet qui mobilise le parlement alors
que l'assemblée est touché par le coran
navires us mercredi le sénat organisé un
débat avec le ministre olivier ferrand
pour faire le point sur les mesures de
santé publique prise par le gouvernement
mais auparavant l'épidémie s'est aussi
invitée dans la séance de questions
d'actualité quand un calme est poussée
de fièvre en séance mercredi le sénateur
de l'oise jérôme bascher était
passablement agacée de l'absence du
ministre de la santé et au cours d'une
question gouvernement ils attaquent
exécutif
il y avait un préparation à avoir cette
crise
quoi que vous en ayez dit je crois qu'il
ne faut pas rompre des consensus sur ces
sujets là il ya des consensus qui
intéresse la nation tout entière et vous
portez la responsabilité monsieur le
sénateur d'avoir rompu ce consensus
à l'occasion de la séance spéciale
consacrée à l'épidémie de coronavirus
organisé dans la soirée
les esprits s'étaient apaisées pour
olivier ferrand un mot d'ordre la
transparence
après avoir rendu hommage au corps
médical le ministre a rappelé la
solennité du moment nous ferons face
grâce à nos professionnels de santé
grâce au sens des responsabilités de
chacun parce que les solidarités se
mesure aussi et peut-être même d'abord
dans l'adversité l'information
l'anticipation la prévention sont les
outils les plus efficaces pour lutter
contre l'épidémie
un débat dans le calme pour faire
remonter les informations venues des
départements mais aussi partager
l'inquiétude de la population sur
certains thèmes et à gauche
les sénateurs n'ont pas manqué de
rappeler la crise qui mobilise tous les
personnels de santé depuis un an
comment le personnel va pouvoir des
ehpad va pouvoir répondre à vos
préconisations monsieur le ministre on
veut bien plus de masques mais encore
faut-il avoir des personnels pour les
porter a ainsi déclaré à juste titre
patrick bourdillon de la fédération cgt
de la santé alors préconisations oui
informations oui transparence oui mais
argent donc moyens financiers et humains
pour soigner l'hôpital c'est personnel
et les patients une séance de nuit
voulue par les sénateurs aussi en
réaction au débat sensationnaliste vue
sur certaines chaînes d'info
l'occasion pour une large majorité de
groupes politiques de redire leur
soutien au gouvernement dans la gestion
de la crise sanitaire
on l'a vu dans l'ensemble atmosphère
était plutôt consensuel mais tout de
même il y a eu cette passe d'armes au
sénat lors des questions d'actualité
votre réaction au fait que le sénateur
jérôme bascher sénateur de l'oise juge
qui a eu un sacré retard à l'allumage de
la part de la réaction du gouvernement
une impréparation at il dit non je
trouve que pour le coup c'est vraiment
faire de la politique politicienne j'ai
pas écouté toute l'intervention de
monsieur ben asher mais je crois que ça
a été très bien gérée depuis le début on
apprendra toujours d'une crise on
affinera toujours nos méthodes de
travail
mais que ce soit en stade 1 c'est à dire
quand on identifiait et on se jetait un
petit peu sur le premier malade en
identifiant de son entourage ou le stade
2 en ayant des mesures qu'ils soient
plus territorialisée en incitant les
habitants des zones très contaminées à
avoir des comportements vertueux je
crois que ça a été relativement bien
géré et moi j'ai le sens paris vers le
stade 3 oui mais j'ai aussi le sentiment
de sa justesse et la campagne des
municipales j'étais à une réunion
publique avec 200 personnes et personne
ne s'est serré la main donc je crois
aussi que le message commence à passer
qu'il faut faire attention se laver les
mains régulièrement éviter les contacts
physiques ce qui prouve bien que le
message a été entendu et que donc le
gouvernement a été écouté on a appris
qu'un député et un fonctionnaire de
l'assemblée étaient infectés par le
coronavirus quelles consignes vous ont
été données par le président de
l'assemblée la même consigne qui est
tous les français mais je pense que
quand on est parlementaire il faut
encore être plus vigilants puisque on à
cet effet ou de un peu de respiration si
je voudrais ou ou toutes les semaines on
part dans nos territoires puis on
revient à l'assemblée donc on se croise
un espace confiné donc il faut être
particulièrement vigilant
c'est pour des élus vous avez vous avez
l'habitude de saluer les gens etc
il faut je crois être très stricte et
dire vraiment parce que nous sommes des
vecteurs soyons encore plus
réservé aux rencontres vous faites
attention non mais on essaye
effectivement d'être de faire attention
aux personnes fragiles de ne pas serrer
la main de se laver les mains
régulièrement de repasser aussi le
relayer les messages du google crois que
c'est très important des demandes de
confinement à ce stade pour l'instant où
vous êtes pas du tout vous n'êtes pas du
tout là ceux qui ont sont contaminés et
doivent être confiné mais après c'est
comme pour le reste des français ceux
qui ont côtoyé les personnes qui aient
été contaminés est ce qu il ya eu des
instructions précises tout à fait en
armes n'a reçu un mail d'informations de
la part du président de l'assemblée
nationale nous rappelant les bonnes
mesures donnant aussi la plaie les jours
sur lesquels avaient pu être identifié
les personnes malades lieu où elle se
trouvait donc aussi pour que chaque
député puisse retracer un peu son emploi
du temps entre sa température
didier gérard jerad surnom mais comme
comme pour l'ensemble des français
honnêtement mais encore une fois il faut
pas créer d'effet de panique faut avoir
un comportement qui est enfin
scientifiquement très rationnelle et
donc si vous n'êtes pas malade il faut
surveiller effectivement si vous avez
été dans un à proximité d'une personne
contaminée faut se surveiller mais il
n'y a pas de raison de porter un masque
si vous n'êtes pas malade il n'y a pas
de raison d'arrêter vos activités tout
en respectant les consignes de vigilance
emmanuel macron dit que le l'épidémie
est inexorable 1 ce sont ses mots est ce
que pour vous le stade iii c'est
inéluctable c'est imminent
moi je suis pas médecin ou
épidémiologistes mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que et olivier ferrand l'a très
bien dit sûr à l'occasion de débats et
des changes
au delà de la mortalité c'est surtout ce
qu'on constate c'est que c'est très
contagieux donc on se transmet très très
facilement et donc oui il y aura
probablement un stade épidémique puisque
c'est ça dont on parle dans le stade 3
c'est à dire toute la france touchée est
contaminée et encore une fois
finalement il ya moins de mesures de
confinement enfin c'est ce qu'il faut
savoir je veux dire aux français parce
que certains disent ya beaucoup
d'injonction contradictoire avec
comprend que ce soit pas facile de
d'avoir le bon comportement mais en
fonction du stade
enfin pourquoi on parle de stade un
stade de stade iii c'est surtout parce
que la stratégie des pouvoirs publics et
notamment tout le secteur hospitalier et
médical évolue en fonction du stade dans
lequel on est donc il y aura moins
de confinement puisque de toute façon le
virus circulera pour autant plus vous
adopter un comportement vertueux en
terme d'hygiène
plus vous aider l'épidémie a à cet homme
alors christophe castaner a voulu
rassurer sur les élections municipales
qui devraient bien se tenir les 15 et 22
mars
pour autant selon une étude opinionway
pour public sénat et la tribune 28% des
sondés se disent inquiets de se rendre
dans un bureau de vote
est ce que ça peut pas faux c'est quand
même quelque peu cette élection ben je
comprends totalement de latitude et
c'est une discussion qu'on a eue hier
avec le mauvais relais ce qu'il fallait
faire il ya beaucoup de mesures qui vont
être mises en place qui vont être
transmises aussi à destination des dd de
l'organiser pour l'organisation des
bureaux de vote
inciter à ce qui est du gel
hydroalcoolique vous savez que vous
recevez aussi vos bulletins de vote au
préalable chez vous donc vous pouvez si
vous avez vraiment une inquiétude
préparé en amont votre bulletin de vote
ce qui vous évite de passer dans l'est
dans l'isoloir et puis effectivement
c'est de garder un petit peu de distance
ne pas se tasser
voilà il ya aussi vous savez dans tous
les villages des heures pleines des
heures creuses
si vous êtes un public plutôt fragile
peut-être qu'ils allaient dans ce qu'on
appelle les heures creuses de vote mais
je crois que dans c'est très important
que la vie continue
on connaît d'autres période épidémique
en france tous les ans et voilà il faut
juste avoir les bons comportements
on passe à préseau troisième tm à
présent avec l'accompagnement pour le
deuil d'un enfant
[Musique]
la proposition de loi sur le congé en
cas de deuil d'enfant c'était l'un des
plus gros couac de la majorité
présidentielle la chambre haute la
finalement adopté à l'unanimité cette
semaine à la porte et la durée de congé
à 15 jours écoutez la sénatrice
socialiste et vice présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales michel
meunier moi je voulais surtout salué ce
pas supplémentaire que nous avons que
nous venons de faire le pas aussi que le
gouvernement a fait non sans mal on sent
qu'il ya quand même eu un traumatisme
entre cette première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale et notre lecture
ici mais tout finit bien et c'est tant
mieux parce que la situation de ses
parents en deuil et nous avons été et
vous avez été unanime
il n'y a pas de mots les mots sont bien
peu de chose par rapport au cataclysme
que cela représente dans les familles
oui michel magne elle souligne et bien
la différence entre l'unanimité au sénat
et ce couac à l'assemblée ce que c'est
frustrant pour vous cette occasion de
manquée à l'assemblée nationale non je
crois que ce qu'il faut reconnaître tout
d'abord c'est qu'il n'y avait pas de
débat sur le fond sur la notion d' avoir
un répit pour le pour le deuil d'un
enfant qui est décédé
ce qui est sûr c'est que la proposition
note telle qu'elle était présentée par
jean loïc où elle avait été travaillé
par un certain nombre de nos
parlementaires notamment christine
cloarec notamment sur la novlangue et
qu'en l'état la proposition de loi
n'étaient pas prêtes elles n'étaient pas
adaptés et donc la majorité fait le
choix de rejeter le jeu c'est pas de
dire est ce qu'on veut ou pas amélioré
la question du congé d'oeil vous savez
que ça va ça a été un symbole désastreux
pour votre majorité auprès de l'opinion
notamment oui bien sûr parce que encore
une fois je veux dire on reste sur
l'intitulé est
on tient des sources très catastrophique
quant à la position de la majorité mais
les députés qui était présent et je vous
entendez dire dire quoi que tout à
l'heure mais c'est pas un couac ils ont
voté en conscience estimant que la
proposition de loi n'était pas prête et
puis la navette parlementaire elle sert
aussi à ça à enrichir le texte
c est l occasion pour quatre de nos
parlementaires de retravailler ce sujet
avec les sénateurs et ce qui prouve bien
que quand on veut même si on a deux
majorités différentes à l'assemblée et
au sénat au pays à risque mais est-ce
que vous en avez tiré des leçons est ce
que vous écoutez davantage les
propositions qui viennent de
l'opposition comme pour les crises
sanitaires on apprend toujours des
moments où effectivement on aurait pu
mieux faire et faire différemment
effectivement on a renforcé notre notre
approche sur les les propositions de loi
d'aidé aux positions mais vous savez je
crois qu'il faut quand même dire quelque
chose c'est que ces propositions soient
elles sont souvent très politique c'est
à dire avec un sujet qui est
particulièrement sensible
la violence faite aux femmes de aurélien
pradié la question du handicap la
question du duo répit de deuil pour pour
les enfants et que on ne résout pas
toujours un problème dans une
proposition de loi en cinq articles
si on peut le faire on sait ce qu'on a
fait avec la ppl pradier c'est ce qui se
passera avec la celle là si on peut le
faire on le fait bien volontiers mais
n'oublions pas que c'est aussi souvent
des textes qui propose des solutions qui
ne sont pas qu'ils sont très incomplète
merci marie le vexer donc le mot de la
fin on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo
[Musique]